antibiotics are fed to almost all of our
conventionally farmed animals we use
them to make these animals grow quicker
and faster and fatter so yeah
when we eat these
animals we actually are eating the
antibiotics that are in their flesh
those antibiotics kill off our gut
microbiome so rather than having this
intense beautiful diverse
tropical rain forest
of tens of thousands of species of
bacteria in our gut after a course of
antibiotics you may be reduced to one or
two bacteria out of ten thousand and it
may take two to three years to get that
back i mean think about it if a forest
burns down and we run in there and we
plant little seedlings
it's going to take 20 or 30 years to get
that forest back and so we've been
really naive
[Music]
hi welcome to the pretty intense podcast
thank you so much for coming i am
grateful to have you and have you
listening today we have a treat it's dr
steven guntry he is a brilliant
cardiologist heart surgeon researcher
and author he wrote the plant paradox
the longevity paradox the energy paradox
and his newest book is called unlocking
the keto code so of course we started
off with the basis of just kind of
ultimate health information
he talks a lot about lectins gut health
how it works how your intestines work
and what truly makes you um you know
unhealthy and to some degree that you
won't even know so
anyway it's amazing information but then
of course we get into the keto code and
unlocking that and the information is
fascinating the things that you think
that are going to
help your body to be the most efficient
energized and leanest and fittest like
all of a sudden the information
flips on its head and so we learn about
the mitochondria we learn about mct oil
and the power of that so it's all about
how to access ketosis um
anyway amazing information i have no
doubt that there's gonna be many of you
that go out and get not only his newest
book unlocking the keto code but
probably some others so enjoy the show
today and of course thank you for coming
if you like what you heard
please hit the subscribe button so that
you can see much more of my content in
the form of clips and other little
things that we create for you guys again
thanks for coming are you practicing
right now are you you said when the
nurse can come knock on the door to
sketch you in an hour i see patients
i
see patients six days a week even
saturday and sunday
and fridays i'm at gundry md my
supplement company so yeah i work seven
days a week
fully
and actually so you know i'm one of the
few people
you're right practicing
is is the correct word because i
everything i talk about everything i've
written is actually based on
25 years of having patients eating
certain things avoid certain things take
a supplement not take a supplement you
know
and
so yeah so i'm one of the few people
that actually you know says this is what
happens when you do this and here's
10 000 patients that have done this but
i can't think of a better way for um
someone to
be able to actually collect the
information and have that beta test with
people and be able to see the trends
of what's happening in the the way that
things are happening even in the way
that food is made and brought to us and
the patterns that fall into place like
for example i tested high for thalium
and then hearing like all of a sudden
everybody's high for thallium because
people are eating kale and kale absorbs
value and what's beautiful about your
books is that i feel like they really
are an evolution
it seems like they build on each other
so i part of what i want to ask you is a
little bit about each book and then end
up getting to where you are now but you
know also you've said that the number
one thing that people come into your
office for is
they want more energy and they don't
want to be quite as fatigued and so
where do you start within your practice
figuring out what the problem is
ah that's a great question um well you
know hippocrates said 2500 years ago
that all disease begins in the gut
and
he didn't have any of the sophisticated
tests we have now uh i don't know how he
knew it
but he was absolutely right and
thanks to work
some of my work worked by dr alessio
fazzano who's now at harvard who
actually
proved for the first time that
certain
foods certain proteins called lectins he
was focused on gluten
actually
attack the wall of our gut and actually
cause the little things that bind our
gut cells together
tight junctions to break
and to actually cause
spaces between the walls of our gut
where
not only can foreign food particles come
through but also bacteria and as i wrote
in the last book the energy paradox
this creates inflammation
locally in our gut 80 percent of all of
our white cells
literally line
the intestinal wall 80 percent
and they're there because that's kind of
our border if you will with the outside
world
and normally that border should be
impenetrable
but it's only one cell thick we have
kind of a design flaw and
that
the space the length of our intestines
is actually the same as a tennis court
so
you know when we're watching in the
australian open for example
that tennis court is inside of us and
it's only oneself there
so any anything that can kind of get
through that you know thin thin thin
membrane our immune system goes oh my
gosh you know we're under attack
and we need we need all the energy that
you have
to fight this war that's you may not
even feel now most people feel it
by you know fatigue or you know other
believe it or not i see so many
particularly women
with depression and anxiety
and they
don't have a clue unfortunately that
this is actually happening uh because of
this war that's starting down in their
gut
you guys have taught me so much women
um because you guys thankfully have a
gut feeling and
men and quite frankly most
medical people have poo-pooed that
feeling that women have
luckily i have a wife two daughters and
three female dogs so um
passion yeah well yeah and luckily i
i've learned that
women have this sense
that we should pay attention to
for the last 20 years i've been urging
women in particular to please keep
looking for a healthcare provider
who will take your complaints seriously
and
once people start doing that once i
started saying gee you know that's
are you sure that that's going on and i
started looking at the blood work
and i go son of a gun you know you're
right um
and let's fix it
um
i mean i'm i can completely attest to
that i
i think that maybe what could be said is
not only to find a practitioner that
takes you seriously and is willing to uh
explore what it is that could be
causing this
um what some may think is imaginary
symptom right but also to
you yourself that person out there to
take your symptoms seriously to take
your intuition seriously probably 2018
i remember thinking to myself like my
body had shifted a little i like gained
a couple of pounds out of nowhere and i
was like man this is so weird and
nothing i did made a dent on it and i
was like
maybe it's just i need to try harder
maybe it's just age maybe it's just that
but my intuition
said my hormones are off i probably
should check them
fast forward now into the end of 2020 i
had another shift like that and i was
like okay this is not okay anymore and
i'm one of those people that does have
great energy and so it's not as easily
noticed in my world
but then i finally went in and i had a
slew of things including leaky gut
including dysbiosis including heavy
metal toxicity i mean just tons and tons
of stuff thankfully i felt decent but
you know the ultimate shift for me was i
i finally had cycle issues and then i
was like well i guess i should probably
do something about this um so i think
that yes following that intuition and
getting in touch with the body and
trusting that is a really important
thing so um do you find that food
is the number one
culprit
yeah um you know hippocrates also said
you know let food be thy medicine and
medicine be that food he was smart
man i don't know how you figure all this
out but
yeah so that's i guess what made me
famous is that a lot of the
healthy foods that we think are good for
us
actually contain um
mischievous little proteins that are the
defense system of the plant against
being eaten which are called lectins and
lectins
bind to the wall of our gut and they
actually flip a switch that breaks these
tight junctions
and the object of the game for a plant
is not to be eaten
and
to make sure that its babies don't get
it eaten its seeds
and their only defense against being
eaten is to try and make their predator
in that case us
not feel well when we eat certain plants
or plant babies and the object of the
game is a smart animal
if it doesn't feel well or if it's not
thriving or even if it's not reproducing
the animal says you know
every time i eat this plant or this
plant baby i don't feel very well i
think i'll go eat something else
the plant wins the animal wins
everybody's happy
humans as we all know are pretty stupid
and so when we eat things that we have
an intuition or we can feel that
something's not right
we take
you know we take prilosec otc or tums or
nexium
we take
antidepressants we take uh aleve advil
and this actually as i write in all my
books makes things worse rather than
better the other thing that i think is
really important that i wrote in the
last book particularly
is
we have
amazing gut dysbiosis now just because
of two things number one the antibiotics
that we take
for whatever um
you couldn't believe the number of
people who have been given antibiotics
for coven 19 which
they don't work
it's a it's a virus folks
number two
antibiotics are fed to almost all of our
conventionally farmed animals and
we use them to make these animals grow
quicker and faster and fatter
um yeah and so yeah
so
when we eat these
animals
we actually are eating the antibiotics
that are in their flesh
and so unbeknownst to us
those antibiotics kill off our gut
microbiome so rather than having this
intense beautiful diverse
tropical rain forest
of tens of thousands of species of
bacteria in our gut
many of us for instance after a course
of antibiotics
you may be reduced to one or two
bacteria out of ten thousand and it may
take two to three years
to get that back
no don't say that yeah it's
unfortunately true uh i mean think about
it if a forest burns down and we run in
there and we plant little seedlings
it's gonna take 20 or 30 years to get
that forest back and so we've been
really naive that oh i can take you know
some probiotics the next day and i'll be
back to normal and unfortunately you got
to build this ecosystem in your time oh
man
that's uh that's sad to hear because
like as a current issue i have
like i said dysbiosis and leaky gut and
of course that stuff doesn't get tested
like monthly but you know i've heard and
and
please explain this to me and and help
us understand that you're like your face
is basically like the inside out of your
gut is that accurate that's accurate
great well my gut sucks right now and
thank god for makeup but i have um and i
got this like 10 years ago it's perioral
dermatitis or something like that and it
basically looks like a little rash right
it's like little bumps around your face
and i got it last summer when all of
this got tested and then i was running a
marathon so i was training a ton and
i've heard that marathons are bad for
leaky gut and gut issues is that correct
oh absolutely it's
one of the worst things you can do for
your health no offense i agree and i was
invited to do another one with the girls
that did it with me and i said
absolutely not but i will cheer you on
problem is though is what do you do
about it so like in my situation i tried
to avoid antibiotics i had a topical
steroid i used it for the last six
months and then i heard it could
actually have a a bad payoff like it
makes things worse is that true too
well you know topical steroids i mean
they cover up the problem but you're
right so what's fascinating is the the
lining of our gut is literally our skin
turned inside out
and
so
what's fascinating is what's happening
on the inside wall of your gut
in a way luckily for many people is
expressed on their skin and so people
with psoriasis people with eczema
people with dermatitis
those are actually an external sign
that that process is going on on the
inside of your gut so if you think about
this
you know red raw rash
you go oh my gosh
i got this red rawness on the inside of
my gut and i don't want that let's say
you can just
let's say you're someone who can see it
on your skin maybe you know i've heard
of a lot of people have um you know
avoid gluten or dairy and that also
helps clear their skin up things like
that so if you're someone out there and
you can see it on your skin that
something's going on what do you do and
in this case like for even something
like what i have going on the the
general fix usually is an antibiotic
right
i hope not but
well what do we do
well so again this is a sign that the
wall of your gut is is under attack
by compounds that produce these gaps in
the wall of your gut
uh about 80
of all my patients now uh have an
autoimmune disease that have been kind
of all around the country of the world
trying to fix because they don't want to
go on immunosuppressant drugs or they're
on them and want to get off
and so
we
we do have the benefit of testing people
for leaky gut and we also have the
benefit of testing people
for food sensitivities
and
what's fascinating is years ago we used
to do food allergy testings where we put
like 100 little pinpricks on your back
and see what you reacted to they're
worthless um really oh yeah they're
worthless
i guess one of the reasons i might be
believable is i'm willing to say i was
wrong
uh based on new data and
yeah i used to use these tests and
they're useless because we now have much
better tests
looking at what are called food
sensitivities
if you have a porous
wall of your gut if you have intestinal
permeability
the foods we eat should be broken down
by all of our digestive enzymes into
simple sugars
simple amino acids from protein and
simple fatty acids from fat and those
should be absorbed through the wall of
our gut
but if you've got spaces gaps
then whole pieces of food
that
were not broken down properly can
actually go across the wall of our gut
so let me give you an example um
let's suppose you eat a lot of kale and
then we do a food sensitivity test
and
all of a sudden you where you're at very
strongly to kale and you go well what
the heck you know that's not right you
know okay i eat a lot of kale and ale is
good for me
well
what happens is if a whole piece of kale
comes across the wall of your gut your
immune system says what the heck is that
i've never i've never seen kale before
you know i've seen simple carbohydrates
that's a foreign protein that's a
foreign body
and i'm going to attack it
and so
it's fascinating years ago when we first
had these tests
uh i'll backtrack for a second about 90
of people who get my book the plant
paradox or one of the subsequent ones
resolve their autoimmune disease with
just by following don't eat these foods
and you know it's exciting um that that
works
but about 10 of people and even 10 of my
patients despite swearing on bibles or
qurans or whatever that they're
following the rules they're they're
better but they're not all the way
better
and so when we do that then we go more
sophisticated looking for food
sensitivities and i can tell you as a
general rule
and i wrote this in my first in the
plant paradox
70 of people with celiac disease which
is the extreme form of gluten
intolerance
a year and a half after following a
gluten-free diet still have celiac
disease by intestinal biopsy which is
the gold standard why
because most gluten-free foods have
lectins that they are reacting to beyond
gluten
so
70 percent of people who are sensitive
to
wheat are sensitive to corn
a hundred percent of people who are
sensitive to wheat are sensitive to oats
including
gluten-free oats um
they're sensitive to quinoa they're
sensitive to buckwheat
they're sensitive to almost all the
pseudo grains and they literally cross
react
the other thing that's unique in my
trouble making patients as i call them
is most of them are sensitive to not
only casein a1 which i write about but
also casein a2 those are the milks right
those are the milks the cows right those
are the two different kind of cows and
most of the really sensitive people are
sensitive to egg white and egg yolk uh
sorry now
yeah the good news is
and then we do a food sensitivity and
quite frankly almonds show up all the
time um
when i first did this years ago we
banned almonds but when i wrote the
plant paradox my editor said man you're
really mean come on give it you know
give us something and i said okay the
the lectin is in the peel of the almond
so you can have blanched almond flour
and you can have marcona almonds and
it's worked pretty well but again some
of my troublemakers
it's almond flour that's the the trouble
and when we get rid of that it's it's
all better
i'll give you a great example um
as an athlete um a couple years ago i
had an
nhl hockey player young man 23 years old
who
developed crohn's disease which is a is
an autoimmune and he was having
20 episodes of bloody diarrhea a day
and he was on two immunosuppressants and
wasn't getting any better
uh he had to drop out of the nhl he
lived with his mother
and i he lost 75 pounds he was a
skeleton
and somebody gave him my book the plant
paradox and he started following it and
he got down to about oh three to four
bloody bowel moves a day but his weight
stabilized so
get a cold call from him and said hey
you know this is the first thing that
has actually worked
yeah but i'm not all the way yet could
we you know
investigate this further and i said yeah
you know this would be great
so we did all this and sure enough he
was sensitive to all forms of dairy and
all forms of eggs and you know gluten
was a disaster and so it was corn et
cetera
so he took all those away from him
and in three months he's back having
normal bowel movements and he's gaining
weight
and
he's still
still his you don't want to have any
bloody bowel moves but he says you know
they're still not formed right i said
okay let's let's do a food sensitivity
and he was having a lot of almond flour
bread almond flour cookies
and sure enough almond flour and vanilla
beans were a couple of his real
troublemakers and
so he took him away
and
he
he calls me back his mother and he
called me back so that was it that was
it he's back to normal and he's back
playing now and so oh my god but it was
like son of a gun such an investigation
it takes so long i mean even i can
attest to that you think it's this and
then that kind of doesn't work and you
go to that and the next thing in the
next thing and you kind of just peel
away the layers of like what is really
the thing and it it takes time so when
you execute it it's like
good shot like that's hard to do oh it's
very hard
and the fact that your book can do it on
its own without actually having to i
mean this is the ultimate scaling option
for someone like you who has this
information to be able to write a book
to help people because you can't
possibly see all the patients that read
this book i still see patients six days
a week because
uh
it's it's very hard for me um
to turn people down uh unfortunately um
the the i mean the heartwarming stories
i like like this fellow but
i mean we had a little uh five-year-old
child from texas who's
had
just
his entire palms of his hands and of his
feet were just bloody
and he couldn't walk
his mother carried him around all of his
life
and he'd been everywhere and he couldn't
go to school because i mean literally
his hands were bleeding and his feet
were bleeding
and you know people would put him on
steroids blah blah blah and nothing was
working and she wrote me a letter and
you know i said oh my gosh let's see
what's going on well this poor young man
had just profound leaky gut in a very
low vitamin d level and hopefully we can
talk about that
and long story short it took us a year
but
he completely healed his hands and feet
but the mother would you know send me
photographs and we'd talk every three
months
and we found you know what he was
sensitive to
and now he's i think he's nine years old
in school thriving in advanced classes
and mom doesn't have to carry him around
anymore that's
you know and so how can i resist you
know
you know i have to keep seeing patients
because they teach me
um
what do you say
just to clean it up because i know a lot
of people that have done
uh a
food sensitivity test
um and it seems like a lot of times the
things that show up on it or the things
you eat
correct so how accurate
is the test itself
and is there a certain gold standard of
a company that tests like is there a
hierarchy if you just sign up for the
one where they send you a box and do the
thing like prick your finger a bit like
is that enough or do you need to go to a
certain level to achieve accurate
results and the fact that so many things
show up on your diet that is what you
eat is that because it's truly
aggravating you
yeah so yeah
there's a lot of questions there but uh
i personally use a lab called vibrant
america i've used lots of labs to me
they're the most accurate
um
the
and it you know it's gonna cost you to
get the the full panel it's gonna cost
you about 400 500 bucks
uh there are other labs that do them uh
cyrex is another one that's quite good
but i like vibrant better
your point is well taken if you're
eating a lot of things and you have
leaky gut
invariably these things you are going to
be sensitized to now the good news
it may take me somebody else a year to
get somebody's leaky gut sealed i was
naive when i started this i said a
couple weeks you'll be fine
no
but the good news is once you seal leaky
gut
we find that you become
desensitized against most of these foods
in fact
i
gave a paper the american heart
association lifestyle and epidemiology
meeting two years ago
showing that 94 of people
who
had celiac disease and profound gluten
intolerance
in a year 94 of them no longer had any
antibodies to gluten their immune system
literally was retrained that gluten was
not an issue for them anymore
so
i mean the extent we find that once you
seal the gut by removing these things
and once you
you literally can retrain the immune
system
not to react to these substances and
that's why
so many of my patients if i can convince
them
that yeah i'm going to make you
miserable and foods i'm going to take
away from you but if we seal your gut
and most the time we can
we'll get these things back into your
diet and and it'll be worth it long term
wow so essentially
the
like testing for food sensitivities
given the fact that yes the things that
you eat show up in your diet because of
course like you said it passes through
particles that are way too big your body
doesn't understand it it hasn't been
broken down
so it's really just an indication of in
your
experience that lectins being probably
the number one thing to eliminate maybe
it needs to be a little more specific as
it goes but that is the best starting
place because the leaky gut is really
just
the it's the
it's the diagnosis but it's not
necessarily that your food test can be
your your your goals you like your it's
not your bible to what to eat and what
not to eat it's just saying you have
inflammation you have your gut is not
operating properly things are seeping
through and yeah if you have a diverse
diet you're going to see a lot of stuff
on your test and and okay interesting
that makes sense because you know i mean
in my experience i had a lot a lot a lot
of things on my on my test that were a
level level red level high um
okay you had said that you wanted to
talk about vitamin d
yeah the vitamin d is that a hormone as
well it is a hormone as well in fact we
should have named it as a hormone long
ago instead of a vitamin
but one of the things that i guess
didn't surprise me but maybe surprised
me early on one you know and i've been
working in this area for 25 years now
is that all of these patients who
presented with autoimmune diseases just
as a start had very low levels of
vitamin d
and
you know i went it's kind of interesting
and then all of these patients with
leaky gut have low levels of vitamin d
and so yeah
so there's there's several important
things um so vitamin d is a hormone i've
never seen vitamin d toxicity yet
and i've been measuring vitamin d levels
every three months for 25 years
uh
i think a normal vitamin d level should
be anywhere from 100 to 150
uh even the cleveland clinic and quest
now say that vitamin d levels up to 150
are completely normal not too high
and so i'll
push my patients vitamin d levels up to
100 to 150 sometimes we'll go higher
vitamin d does two things
we have
as as the cells in the wall of our gut
are are hurt by these lectins and other
compounds
there's a bunch of replacement cells
stem cells that are ready to take the
place of these damaged cells
it's kind of like the old revolutionary
war movies where you got lots of liners
of soldiers and the first guys go down
and the next guys step up right
right well that second line
has to be pushed into place by vitamin d
they sit there and twiddle their thumbs
and go what when am i supposed to do
something and it's vitamin d that pushes
them into place that's number one
number two
we know that people with
autoimmune diseases their
immune cells their white blood cells
normally should be sensitive to vitamin
d vitamin d basically says hey guys
relax um
go have a donut and a smoke if we think
of them as cops
and that's not to generalize but just
cool it don't carry an uzi around every
everything's fine
but we know that people with autoimmune
diseases their immune cells do not
listen to vitamin d properly so you
basically have to
literally hit him
with a sledgehammer to quiet down
so it's this two-fold effect and
so
almost all human beings should be on
5000 international units of vitamin d
or 125 micrograms any of my autoimmune
patients we start them on 10 000
international units
the university of california san diego
one of the
expert centers in vitamin d thinks the
average american should take 9600
international units of vitamin d a day
to have an adequate level the average
american
they found and other people found that
you cannot produce vitamin d toxicity at
40 000 international units a day you're
safe and you're safe and i have some of
my really tough autoimmune patients on
40 50 000 a day
that because of the bioavailability to
their body of what they actually absorb
and do something with excellent question
it turns out when you've got a leaky gut
you do not absorb it well and
long before
we had measurements of leaky gut i used
vitamin d levels to decide when the gut
was sealed and so i'd be pushing pushing
pushing vitamin d and i'd have somebody
on 30 000 units and
and their vitamin d would be 50.
and then on the next blood test their
vitamin d is you know 140.
great you know we're there let's start
backing down now and it's actually been
a very reliable
way so you're right
people with leaky gut you just can't
absorb vitamin d well and
once we seal you then your vitamin d
needs go down
it that makes perfect sense what are
some other kind of hormones that are at
play that are
big factors in
overall health
well um
one of the things that i wrote about in
the last book the energy paradox that i
think people need to know
is
glyphosate the active ingredient in
roundup
is now
omnipresent in our diet
it's in
and people
you know we
we learned about roundup with gmo foods
and you know roundup was developed to
you know spray soybeans and kill the
weeds and the soybeans would die blah
blah blah
and so everybody thinks of roundup as
being sprayed on gmo foods
but and 95 of corn in the united states
is
genetically modified same with canola
but now what's happened in the last 10
years is the roundup is no longer just
being used on gmo crops it's now being
used on conventional crops as what's
called a desiccant
these large corporations have to bring
these multi-million dollar harvesters to
a field
on a certain day
to be efficient so rather than wait
for the field to ripen and dry
they kill the plants with roundup and
then they die and then they're dry and
so they basically say okay you know
field in iowa number seven is
we're gonna have the harvesters there on
next day spray it with roundup so we can
harvest it
and so nobody's sitting around washing
the wheat or the oats or the corn of
roundup afterwards they
they don't have to declare it
and so it's fed to our animals it's fed
to us almost all grains the united
states are contaminated with roundup
almost all vineyards in the united
states are sprayed with roundup too
mine's clean organic we're organic
very good
bless you yes and uh you know
here in europe and it's you know it's
hard to get uh organic or biodynamic
wine in the united states and bless you
for doing that uh because you know most
of our wines are contaminated with with
roundup now why should we worry about
that well it turns out that
glyphosate is
sadly now known to actually cause
intestinal permeability leaky gut
without doing anything else
and roundup is
roundup was patented as an antibiotic
glyphosate was patented as an antibiotic
was it ever administered as an
antibiotic first before it became
something they sprayed on okay wow but
it's considered an antibiotic yeah it's
it's it's that's what antibiotics do
exactly and
so
one of the things that they assured us
was that don't worry
roundup is not absorbed and it can't
kill you because you nice people don't
run what's called the shikamate pathway
and that's a really fun word the
shikamate pathway
and yeah but but plants use the
shikamite pathway what they didn't tell
us was that our bacteria in our gut
use the shikimate pathway
and that's how they patented it as an
antibiotic but they didn't bother to
tell any of us
so
every time you eat a roundup sprayed
grain or bean or corn
you're inadvertently killing off your
gut microbiome and causing leaky gut
even though you're very fastidious about
you know
choosing things and it's apparently
allowed and present in as you said all
even organic products correct yeah the
problem with that is and that you know
the roundup is sprayed on field
and there's wind drift and
there's i i have a friend who's a
biodynamic wine maker in santa barbara
beckman vineyards but
um
he's he's all certified organic
biodynamic but he's got this one area of
his property that's not certified and i
said well why don't you certify that
he said well i can't because the guy
next to me sprays with roundup and it
drifts and we can detect it so we're not
you know we're not gonna you know
we we know it
yeah and so and that's part of the
problem you know there was a big to do
that there were a lot there are a lot of
organic oats and oat products
that have glyphosate in them and oat
milk is all the rage oh i know and oh
oats are some of the worst lectin
containing grains there are and i have
so many you know healthy people
who
are developing symptoms of leaky gut and
they're having their oat milk and
they're having their you know
gluten-free oats and
when we
you know show them the data they go oh
my gosh you know what what have i been
doing
so what are the big buckets of lectins
then for people listening where they're
like okay i need to get started i'm
going to go get your plant paradox book
i'm going to continue on and get the
longevity paradox and the energy and all
of it because i know this is going to
work
where do they start with the buckets
yeah and the new book unlocking the keto
oh we're going to get there next time
i'm very curious
as soon as you answer this we're
definitely getting to unlocking the keto
code because i'm kind of fascinated by
that all right rule number one is what i
tell you not to eat is far more
important than what i tell you to eat so
try to stay away from all grains except
millet and sorghum millet and sorghum do
not contain lectins
all the other grains do if you've got to
have grains like or pseudo grains like
quinoa or buckwheat
pressure cook them that will destroy the
lectins but you cannot pressure cook
wheat rye barley or wrote it will not
work you cannot destroy gluten with
pressure cooking sadly
that's number one number two beans beans
and legumes have really high lectin
content however
you can soak your beans and then
pressure cook them and you will destroy
the lectins there's two companies now
that have pressure cooked beans eden and
jovial and i have no relationship to
them and i'm a big fan of
detoxified beans and lentils
but you got to understand you've got to
you know de-thorn
the mischief makers in beans so are you
talking about from a raw bean or are you
saying even if it can't get a can even
in human can the only two canned beans
that have been pressure cooked are
eaten and jovial okay
uh peanuts and cashews they are not uh
they are not nuts they are actually
beans right cashew is actually a part of
the poison ivy family and there is
actually cashew pickers disease they get
terrible burns and boils on their hands
and so if you think it's a good idea to
eat poison ivy then keep eating your
cashews and your cashew milk
and you wouldn't believe the number of
people with skin rashes that are
described in the dermatological
literature that cashews were the culprit
okay so just just think of swallowing
poison ivy and then wondering why you
might have something on your face i'll
throw them all away now aha yeah i've
i've had so many people who've listened
to other podcasts and then write me
something it was the cashews you know it
was the cashew milk and it was the
cashew cheese
thank you
uh then the nightshade family uh
nightshade family potatoes eggplant
tomatoes
goji berries and peppers those are all
part of the nightshade family not onions
no no onions are great for you
yeah onions leeks garlic they're
actually really good for feeding
friendly bacteria great so those are
those are the troublemakers now the good
news about that family in general
the peel and the seeds of tomatoes and
peppers are where the lectins are
so if you peel and de-seed them like any
good italian would before making tomato
sauce
then you're pretty safe okay all right
that's amazing thank you all right now
on to unlocking the keto code i mean
there's just
you know there's so this is such a hot
topic um you know when you just put into
like keto fasting all this stuff you're
just like okay
carnivore or even like you know feel
like michaela peterson has made the
lions diet a thing now so
what is it what are you trying to say
with this book what is the diet what are
you saying is the problem and what is
the solution
well so i've i've had a ketogenic
version of my
diet since i did it and it's in actually
all the books
and interestingly enough if you look at
the ketogenic version of the plant
paradox there's a whole lot of
carbohydrates in there and people
do extremely well on that program
so when i was doing the energy paradox
my last book
i wanted to kind of explain
how
ketones
made
your mitochondria the little energy
producing organelles in all of our cells
really super efficient and really highly
efficient at burning fat for fuel
and i like to document with studies with
evidence what i say
and so as i'm
looking up all the studies that i'd
accrued
and started reading them even closer and
i'd go wait a minute
this is everything i'm saying and all
the keto experts are saying is wrong
keto is
ketones are a horrible fuel uh they are
not some super fuel they
yeah sorry
um this is i knew you were gonna tell me
something that was gonna be like what
yeah
and i go what and i go wait a minute you
know but you know i'm teaching and
everybody's teaching and all the keto
experts are teaching that they're a
super fuel
and they're not uh this was actually
worked out uh at harvard in the nih back
in the 70s 80s 90s and even in the 2000s
on humans
so um briefly
even at a full
ketogenic diet where you're producing
massive amounts of ketones
ketones can only supply 30
of the energy needs of a human being 30
and yeah sorry um this was dr owens work
from harvard uh published in 2004
and
even at full ketosis ketones can only
meet 60 to 70 percent of the brain's
energy needs and the brain still needs
30 to 40 percent glucose sugar to run
oh
wow because i feel like the the word on
the street is like you can use fat for
fuel or
or sugar for fuel those are your two
fuels the main fuels that they use the
body uses first that's true that's true
muscles
will
use
ketones after a three-day starvation
fast
muscles will use ketones as a fuel
but as you go beyond three days muscles
shift to using free fatty acids as a
fuel
and
could care less about ketones
so what are ketones doing well
ketones
free fatty acids are mitochondria love
they'll make they'll make atp just fine
the problem with free fatty acids are
that they're too big
to get through what's called the
blood-brain barrier it's literally a
barrier for things to pass through to
get to the brain
and so you could have free fatty acids
floating all around
but they can't get to the brain so what
what do we get free fatty acids from so
free fatty acids come out of our fat
okay okay so
it's some energy that gets liberated
from the fat that can be used in the
body correct as a fuel okay your
mitochondria normally
if you have what's called metabolic
flexibility
you should be able to
burn sugar as a fuel and then as the
sugar dries up you shift to burning free
fatty acids as a fuel
and
the best example is a hybrid car
while you're burning gasoline you're
hopefully charging the battery so it's
like well you're eating carbohydrates
and protein whatever is extra you'll put
into storage is fat
if the gasoline runs out then we call on
the battery to start supplying power for
keep us moving
so the fat is our battery
and free fatty acids are
broken pulled out of the battery to
power the engine when glucose is no
longer available
that's how we're designed now the bad
news is
that and i talk about this in the book
50
of normal weight americans do not have
metabolic flexibility 50 percent cannot
switch
cannot tap their battery overweight
americans 88
of them are metabolically inflexible and
obese americans 99
are metabolically inflexible so the
important thing about this with ketones
is that
ketones are only made normally by free
fatty acids coming out of fat cells
going to the liver
and the liver converts them into
short chain saturated fats that are
water soluble called ketones or ketone
bodies and they can go to the brain
and serve as a temporary
emergency fuel for the brain until
we find some glucose
okay so it doesn't get used right away
it's just it's like there's a delay it's
just yeah it's like hold on you know
food's coming hold on don't die but you
know this will do for now
the problem is if you're not
metabolically flexible and you stop
eating or even you eat a 80 fat diet
insulin people have heard of insulin
resistance by now if you're not
metabolically flexible you have a high
insulin level and insulin
actually blocks fat from being released
from fat stores
so you could have
tons of fat but if your insulin level is
elevated and i can tell you that most
americans insulin level is elevated
then you could stop eating you could eat
an 80 fat diet and it may take weeks for
insulin to fall enough that you can
start putting free fatty acids out to be
turned into ketone
and that explains the
keto flu the atkins blues and it's not
even that easy to get into ketosis from
what i've learned it's actually very i
listened to dr rhonda patrick talking
about that and how she had to keep
testing herself and she just had to keep
pouring fat onto things to even get into
ketosis and she could get kicked out
super easily by too much spinach
but i've got the trick
okay
and that's unlocking the keto code
believe it or not you don't have to eat
a lot of fat to get into ketosis okay
yay
one of so
one of the tricks that i in all my books
um
most people now have heard of mct oil
medium chain triglycerides
medium chain triglycerides
uh
are absorbed as a fat in a totally
different way than any other fat they're
absorbed directly through the wall of
our gut
and they unlike any other fat go
directly to our liver you know do not
pass go to not collect 200
and are made instantly into ketones
no matter what you're eating so you
could you could have a plate of spinach
you could have a fruit salad please
don't but you could have a fruit salad
and take a tablespoon of mct oil and you
will be in ketosis
jeez nice
that's really helpful i've got some of
that yeah now
mct is medium chain triglycerides and
generally are named after
the goat kapra
and so there's capric acid caprylic acid
caprolic acid they're all words for goat
why did they name it for goat turns out
that goat milk and sheep melt is 30
medium chain triglycerides mcts
yes can i eat goat cheese then so you
can have goat cheese you can have sheep
cheese you can have goat yogurt you can
have sheep yogurt i'm gonna switch out
for my cashew fake goat cheese cashew
and for the real thing yeah and so you
will make ketones just by eating goat
cheese and sheep cheese and i've got
tons of recipes in the book of so you
could i mean you could you know have
yourself some goat yogurt and put some
polyphenols which we'll talk about in a
bit maybe in it and you'll go into
ketosis the third way to do it is that
time restricted eating
cutting the window that you eat food
down to about six to eight hours a day
so
is will guarantee you that you will if
you're metabolic metabolically flexible
you'll start making ketones about eight
hours after your last meal and by 12
hours after your last meal you're
you're humming in ketones
but what's important and this was a
study of italian cyclists
what's important is you want to go
beyond just 12 hours eating and 12 hours
not eating you want to get to this sweet
spot
of about 16 hours of not eating that's
about an eight hour eating window
and in italian athletes um and you know
you're a great athlete
so
what they did is they took these guys
and put them on a training table for
three months and they all had to eat the
exact same food
the one group ate in a 12-hour window
they breakfast at eight o'clock they had
lunch at one o'clock and they had to
finish dinner at eight o'clock
the other group same food
their first meal was at one o'clock in
the afternoon that was break fast their
second meal was four o'clock in the
afternoon their third meal they had to
finish by eight so what's the same
calorie amount same calorie rent
schedule got it right yeah that's it
lo and behold
the only the shortened eating window
guys they had the same athletic
performance but they lost weight the
other guys didn't lose any weight
and
one of these markers that i follow for
longevity insulin-like growth factor
igf-1 plummet plummeted in the shortened
window athletes didn't change a bit in
the other ones
so it was just the timing so in the book
it explains why that happened
ketones were being produced
for about four hours longer in the
shortened window athlete and what
ketones actually do
and that's why it's called unlocking the
keto code is ketones are actually the
key
to making
mitochondria
protect themselves and to actually
become
inefficient at burning calories and it's
called
uncoupling inefficient
inefficient and that's how they lost
weight and it turns out
that
telling mitochondria
to
protect themselves
to make more of themselves get some more
guys to help out
and
to actually waste calories is actually
how ketones work and it's
it's 180 degrees opposed to
how we used to think ketones
made you lose weight how how did you i
mean it obviously it's counterintuitive
to think
you're training your mitochondria to
protect itself and not use
calories because you think any any any
disposal service that i can use to burn
calories is part of my
the sum of me and what if i
lose weight or gain weight
correct but it's all wrong
and this was actually discovered by
a researcher by the name of martin brand
in 2000
and he wrote a very
small paper anybody can look it up
uncoupling to survive that's the name of
the paper
and he showed
yeah and uncoupling to survive and he
basically proved that if
you were starving to death
then you would have to have a mechanism
to tell mitochondria who make the energy
to protect themselves at all costs
because if the mitochondria don't make
it who cares um and to put all their
resources into making more of themselves
who cares about the muscles who cares
about anybody else protect yourself
and so he showed that the more
mitochondria protect themselves by not
trying as hard to make energy because
energy production damages mitochondria
and then he showed that if you look at
super old people thriving in 105
they have the most uncoupled
mitochondria of anybody
because they wear out is that right
that's exactly right making energy is
really damaging and so we lose
mitochondrial function over time bingo
because it wears it down so and the book
is how to get your mitochondria to
protect themselves at all costs wow what
are some other i mean i've kind of been
dabbling in some of these spaces of
mitochondrial function are there some
other things that we can do to
um
give it more of it to protect itself
polyphenols okay so polyphenols are all
those really cool
yellow orange red purple blue compounds
in plants
and strange but true plants actually
have mitochondria that are called
chloroplasts
and oxygen damages our mitochondria but
we have to have oxygen can't live with
it can't without it
plants sunlight damages
plant mitochondria but they have to have
sunlight but it's damaging so they
produce all these colorful compounds
called polyphenols to guess what
uncouple their mitochondria their
chloroplasts to protect them
then
it's kind of like circle of life from
the lion king
when we eat plants that contain
polyphenols
those polyphenols in turn
uncouple our mitochondria
so this idea that we should be eating
the rainbow
really should be rewritten
we should be eating to uncouple our
mitochondria so
by list i mean for instance the spice
trade in the in the middle ages they
didn't know it but they were engaging in
uncoupling their mitochondria
olive oil contains polyphenols that
uncouples your mitochondria i think
you're olive oil's number one fan oh
thank you yeah and it has the most
polyphenols of any olive oil 30 times
more so and that explains why the
mediterranean diet with all its brightly
colored fruits and vegetables and the
olive oil and the red wine
perpetuates this longevity and there's
two blue zones sardinia in the nagoya
peninsula in costa rica guess what their
number one food is goat and sheep cheese
i'm moving there i'm moving there
and the sardinians who live up in the
mountain that have goat and sheep
live much longer than the sardinians who
live down by the sea and the only
difference in their diet is the goat and
sheep cheese because they're
they're making ketones and the ketones
are from the mcts in the goat sheep
cheese and the ketones are uncoupling
their mitochondria
whoa so this is blowing me away and i
know we have to wrap up and you have to
go because you have patience because
you're an amazing human and you still
see people six days a week
so can we get these polyphenols and take
you know consume mct oil in any form or
fashion is it best to do
it in your coffee in the morning to
start your day is that a great start and
and maybe as a last question could you
is there
do you have to completely go zero
calories in that 16 hour window or could
you have mct oil in your coffee or
something yes so mct won't affect it it
turns out that a good friend of mine
walter longo from usc
um
has shown in humans that if you eat
a nut bar and he has a nut bar called
the fast bar and i have some but if you
eat a nut bar or a handful of nuts not
cashews they're not nuts
uh you will not stop ketosis
for that four hours so that's actually
exciting so yeah have some mct oil or
have a hand butter
uh butter actually if you get ghee it's
much safer got it because
most butter unfortunately has some
casein a1 in it a1 d is better
got it
okay uh i'm just i can't wait to read
that book that's gonna be amazing thank
you so much for doing so much research
and helping so many people it's truly
truly magic thank you
well thanks for having me appreciate it
all right enjoy enjoy the rest of your
day and all your patience and let's seal
your leaky gut uh honestly i need help
because i'm on my way to the
dermatologist tomorrow
and i know they're going to probably
tell me some kind of antibiotic but
try try to resist thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today i hope you enjoyed it if you like
what you heard today and you want to
hear more please click on the subscribe
button